[Music]
who's got two thumbs and is ready to
watch a new TV show this gal and if
you're anything like me I have got good
news because the brand new ABC me show
teenage boss has just started teenage
boss follows a bunch of different
families when their monthly household
budget is put in the hands of the kids
it's a cool look at the way we spend and
use money and it's all hosted by Eddie
Wu a high school math teacher and 2018
Australian local hero of the year so
we're gonna chat teenage boss with the
host himself right now
it's Eddie whoo hey hey hey yo you good
thanks all right so let's talk about
teenage boss it's basically where you
give the entire family budget to the
kids to handle so did any of the
teenagers go on a massive power trip as
soon as they got the money it answer
that question I'd say how would you feel
if you didn't get to make any decisions
about how you know what clothes you had
to buy what phone you should have or use
all those little ins and outs that
affect every little aspect of your life
and suddenly you get to make all the
calls all the decisions and even make
them for other people like mum and dad
so I think it's pretty fair to say lots
of teenagers were very excited about
that prospect
you know what fair enough I feel like
I'd be excited too all right so what was
your favorite part of making teenage
boss there's so much fun working with
teenagers and helping them to learn
about the ins and outs of managing money
I mean that's what makes me tick as a
teacher helping people wrap their head
around three key concepts and gain new
skills and it's been quite an adventure
to helping kids actually get into their
lives and help them work out what do I
do with all these finances when it's
really my family's money and real
decisions that affect my life that's
better than a fund so have there been
any lasting changes in the families in
the way that they manage or cut down
spending one of the things I've loved
the most is seeing not just the
teenagers but actually the parents say
wow you know what we learnt a lot this
month about how we as a family spend
money and so I know people have decided
they're going to be not eating out so
much some people are gonna be saving for
big goals like travel and I think it's
had an effect on everyone who's taken
part in the experiment but it's not all
hard and scary being the boss so
what is some of the fun stuff it's heaps
of fun being able to say you know what
these things aren't dreamed of doing for
ages can I make them a reality alright
so what are your top 3 tips on budgeting
so when it comes to budgeting I would
say tip number 1 is have a plan actually
write something out put it down on paper
maybe talk to the people around you your
family get some advice secondly make
sure you know the difference between
needs and wants there are lots of things
which are really important and then
there are other fees which would be nice
but you've got to make sure there are a
second priority even if you want them a
lot as compared to your needs I think
the last major tip is be flexible a lot
of teenagers they made their plan and as
the month progressed all kinds of things
that they didn't expect would crop up
and they had to adapt so even if you
make a plan be willing to change it and
be really to roll with the flow and say
yep
that's ok we can change our plan and
make adjustments that is awesome advice
and Eddie thank you so much for joining
us on news to me it's a pleasure to see
you guys